you probably know your blood type a B
universal donor
you might even carry a card on you so
that in case of emergency we won't get
the wrong type of blood but do you know
how your blood type was actually
identified in the first place
blood type can be determined in two ways
forward blood grouping which detects
markers on the blood cells themselves
and reverse blood grouping which detects
antibodies present in the blood plasma
either type of test today takes a long
time requires technical training and can
be expensive researchers have been
working on a new blood typing test that
is not only easy to use but can be done
on-site
as little as thirty seconds a small
blood sample is dropped into the middle
of the testing strip a color change in
either observation window delivers the
results this test can perform forward
and reverse blood grouping at the same
time which gives more confidence in the
result a similar tests can also be used
to determine rare blood types after the
blood is loaded onto the disk
spectroscopy is used to automatically
determine the blood type so a person
doesn't need to interpret the color
change and the test can be done by
someone who's colorblind
until now paper-based tests were reliant
on blood samples that had already been
spun in a centrifuge which takes time
and experience the introduction of these
test strips has the potential to not
only save time and money in the hospital
remote areas with few resources rapid
blood typing could be done by non
trained users and blood supplies can be
stretched
[Music]
[Music]